[Musique]
jour et nuit de son fils cache
lourdement handicapée depuis 14 ans son
seul répit il le trouve dans cette
maison
c'est leur deuxième famille la maison
accueille les enfants gravement malade
pour des séjours de répit et offrent des
soins palliatifs mais jusqu'à nouvel
ordre ces portes resteront fermés
tout son personnel est appelé en renfort
à l'hôpital pour enfants de Calgary les
enfants requérants des soins de fin de
vie seront transférés en milieu
hospitalier service de santé Alberta
explique que ses ressources sont
nécessaires pour faire face à la flambée
des hospitalisations dû aux infections
respiratoires depuis quelques semaines
les urgences de l'hôpital pour enfants
débordent tellement qu'on a dû installer
cette remorque chauffée pour gérer les
admissions Jeffrey wood n'est pas moins
sidéré par la fermeture de la maison de
répit
il ne peut pas concevoir que certaines
familles devront vivre les derniers
moments de vie de leur enfant lourdement
handicapé dans le chaos hospitalier
d'autant que pour ce père de 56 ans la
situation actuelle aurait pu être évitée
si la province en faisait plus pour
encourager la vaccination
en Alberta moins de 15% des enfants de
moins de 14 ans son vaccinés contre la
grippe et moins de 5% des enfants
âgés de 5 ans au moins sont immunisés
contre la covid
ne sait pas combien de temps il lui
reste avec son fils à sa naissance il y
a 14 ans on lui donnait tout juste deux
mois à vivre
c'est un ange tombé du ciel dit-il mais
pour adoucir sa chute il a besoin de
toute l'aide possible
et c'est un Levasseur a du Canada
Calgary